counsel to the president Kellyanne
Conway if the President of the United
States of America invites the opposition
party to the White House and wants to
avoid a government shutdown
don't they at least shouldn't they have
the decency to show up for that meeting
instead of the stunts that Nancy Pelosi
and Chuck Schumer showed today in a word
yes they should because they're not
they're representing the opposition
party though there is a minority leaders
of the two chambers in Congress and it
is a major disappointment especially
when you see the president's reaction in
North Korea firing its highest missile
to date Sean he's saying let's not play
politics with funding our military and
keeping us strong and let's not leave
that on the altar of a liberal agenda I
find it really regrettable that Nancy
Pelosi took time out of her sunday
schedule to go and call John Conyers an
icon and yet his name calling our
president and a right to due process and
and and that's right but but I want to
say today was a great example as to why
Donald Trump and his party prevailed and
why the other party has failed it's
based on ideas and bedrock principles
the president and his party today
through the Senate Finance Committee
they forged ahead and they got this tax
bill passed out of committee it's a
great step forward to making sure that
our corporate our job creators get a
lower rate you know the president just
had a five-nation Asia trip in the five
nations that president Trump visited
guess which one has the highest
corporate tax rate among them all us the
United States of America that is
completely unacceptable and it's this
president who's trying to work with both
parties in both chambers in Congress
Sean to make sure that this job creators
tax rate is lowered make sure the middle
class gets a tax break they they deserve
repatriate the trillion dollars worth of
wealth and just simplify the code why
are we spending billions of dollars in
billions of hours every single year
trying to comply with the code so he's
making good on promises I also think he
was very respectful to process today
saying to the Senators listening to
their concerns you have a few of them
coming forward and talking about small
businesses and what the relief they'll
get the president is listed very
patiently to those concerns others
talking about the deficit and so he he
went to the Senate today to say thank
you for working through the process
encouraging them to come forward bring
their concerns to reconciliation and get
this tax cut on his desk the Democrats
have spent all of 2017 talking about the
presidential election in 2016 and the
presidential election 2020 they've build
a no I gave one policy can't
we're differently there was ten trillion
dollars more in new spending and eleven
trillion dollars in new taxes that's
right that's that's why they're the
minority party there Sean it's why they
lost 1000 seats in state legislatures in
the house in the Senate in the
governorships and of course the biggest
prize of all the white house it's based
on the policies Donald Trump and Mike
Pence prevailed on policies and they're
trying to make good on those but the
Democratic Party has been reduced to
carrying around a stop sign their code
word is resistance and that's all
they're doing including today and the
people see that I travel this country
weekly for the White House and I don't
go to curated Republican audiences I'm
out of manufacturing plants I'm talking
to small business owners I have no idea
what these people's politics are and how
much care I hate Trump and Russia Russia
Russia that's it and feigning outrage
after they call the president every name
in the book yeah all right we're really
supporting these for this president they
want to see they're they appreciate the
fact that on North Korea he and the UN
ambassador Haley have gotten 15 to 0-2
Kentucky and unanimous votes to sanction
North Korea she's she's hosting another
meeting tomorrow about this urgency and
the economic and diplomatic isolation in
North Korea will continue if they
continue to do this this is the
president showing leadership but the
Democratic Party is talking about
presidential elections a set of passing
policy and I'm telling you the American
people see it too a person even folks
who didn't vote for this president come
up and tell us all the time they can't
stand the constant negativity resistance
lies and the rest of all the blather
they want a government that functions
and he's leading the way I don't see
with North Korea and again I would
be privy to whatever new weaponry that
our Defense Department and our military
have probably designed in recent years
and I assume there are a lot of Secrets
and I'm hopeful there are because on
paper responding to North Korea as they
fire missiles over Japan and into
Japanese waters as they threaten Guam in
Hawaii it's going to get to the point
where the options are not good take it
off the pad take it out of the sky and
we don't know what this madman will do
then we take out their nuclear sites you
got to worry about nuclear fallout you
got to worry about do they have a
missile site that we don't know about
firing into South Korea or Japan or Guam
or Hawaii or the continental United
States so I would say as he now is
precipitating us and pushing us to the
brink there's not a lot of good options
and a lot of people will die will China
play the role they should play well this
president certainly has forged a an
improved relationship with the president
of China from the beginning particularly
on the matter of North Korea trying to
work together to contain this North
Korea is everybody's problem and anybody
who doubted that saw that today this
president in bringing on board and
talking to Japan and China and South
Korea and again are you and the UN
Security Council voting twice
unanimously in an unprecedented fashion
to sanction North Korea shows that the
world is responding to Donald Trump's
leadership as president and
commander-in-chief Shawn he inherited a
big mess with North Korea and in many
other places but if you can you can show
one big distinction between Donald Trump
and Hillary Clinton there were many all
right everything all national security
foreign policy they weren't his ideas
prevailed he assured us he had a deal
and he used American taxpayer dollars
Kim jong-il Kim jong-un's father are you
confident after the meeting today are
more confident that the Senate that has
really been fairly ineffective that
they'll actually get this tax bill
across the finish line we're confident
we're optimistic and we certainly hope
that Democrats will come aboard to they
may not be votes
49 50 51 but hopefully those will those
who are in states that are where people
are suffering in the middle class needs
a break that they'll come on board as
well but we're hopeful because we've
been listening to those concerns and we
and we know that those senators know
they have an open line to the president
and to his economic team to express
themselves talk to the vice president
exactly so I'm promised well they've all
promised what Donald Trump has promised
which is tax cuts for their constituents
and Sean let me make clear this is not
important to Republicans or to the
Senate it's important to the American
people we're here for the job creators
the job seekers to serve them they're
supposed to serve the Forgotten men and
women in poverty on food stamps and out
of work Kelly and great to see it